[Music]
I think just the biggest thing is just
to you know love the game you know
that's the big thing why I've continued
for like so many years now
um yeah just finding passion in what you
love you know there's always times when
like chess feels kind of boring or you
just don't want to stare at it for hours
and hours
um but always what keeps me coming back
is just that I love the game I love
winning and yeah hopefully I continue
that year
um well I would say you have to love the
game because if you don't have any
passion then it's very hard to improve
so first learn to enjoy the process and
then once you've figured that out you
can improve quite easily for me at least
for me when I was growing up I was just
playing the game just for the passion of
it I didn't really have any clear goal
in mind and um I'd say the same just uh
play the game if you enjoy it you don't
know where it'll take you and just uh
see how it goes I would tell them to aim
high but I wouldn't say to chase that
goal too much I would say just focus on
improving whatever you need to improve
at the time and just try to play For the
Love of the Game not for like a title
you might be chasing or a rating you
might want I'd say the first main thing
in in order to become better at
basically anything is to enjoy the game
otherwise everything will feel like
torture so my advice is enjoy the game
and work on the areas which you feel
that are not up to up to the mark and
yeah work hard and everything else will
come your way I think the big thing is
you have to be self-motivated I know a
lot of young players you know their
their parents push them a lot which is a
good thing
um but I think in the end the people who
make it really far are the ones who are
always hard on themselves and pushing
themselves to be better regardless of
what level they're at so I think that's
the number one thing just that sort of
attitude of being tough on yourself and
always pushing yourself to get to that
next level well I mean I've solved
around 1200 or 1300 hours of Chess Tempo
when I was a kid and that helped me
immensely and uh one of the things I
regret was not having a solid repertoire
from the beginning um during my game so
it's very important to play very solid
openings from the beginning of your
chess career because if you get an
opening trouble uh repeatedly you'll
find yourself under more problems during
the game in early in your career you
should try to be familiar with different
Physicians for example and also like
different approaches I think it's really
important about really enjoying the game
enjoying playing enjoying sewing puzzles
enjoying practicing and especially with
availability of resources nowadays with
streamers
um all these resources it's not hard to
improve but I think it's important to
kind of find that motivation when you
begin to kind of get better and the more
you enjoy the game of course the farther
you'll go I think like passion and trust
is very very important especially for
young kids and so I love that these days
there's so many resources to to get into
chess like YouTube you got streamers
like Gotham chess and ikaro who you know
are fun to watch and I think the problem
that kids face is that they get bogged
down in the opening Theory or these like
theoretical things that they feel like
they have to know but it's important for
them to First just learn the the fun
things about Chess the tactics the fun
the exciting the attacking chess so I
think that's the most important thing
foreign